fish and he is in love with the sound of
his own voice and his own attacks
he doesn't actually check the fact
they don't have a plan for the future of
the Canadian economy on this side we're
investing in and leveraging technologies
that are cutting emissions and creating
good jobs and come by chance in
Newfoundland and Labrador for example
and we're making sure that it's no
longer free to pollute while giving
Canadians money back very honorable
leader of the opposition
so the High School Drama teacher over
here accuses others of liking the sounds
of their own voices this from a guy who
if he were made of chocolate he would
eat himself
yes Mr Speaker I was a high school
teacher before getting into politics and
I'm having a little
break what exactly the job that the
leader of the opposition had before
getting in touch
yes and uh yes and he left right in the
middle of the semester and I'm having
trouble remembering why
Peter the opposition uh continues on his
personal and his partisan attacks
I continue to deal with it I'm sorry
what part I have a question for all of
you to reflect on I don't want anybody
to shut shut the answer out this is this
is not a question I want an answer what
part of while somebody is speaking we
sit quietly and listen do we not
understand
email if you want once we're done and
you can explain to because I don't
understand that I've looked through the
history of Parliament and there was one
case where the speaker decided that he
had had enough of question period and he
left
in fact the entire city was adjourned
for around 30 minutes and I'm really in
the mood for that today so I'm going to
ask the prime minister to start over
from the beginning I have a hypothesis
for you Mr Speaker
why you're seeing this behavior in the
house have we ever seen a prime minister
who has so little worthiness of the
functions that he occupies
illegal election funding industrial
espionage
Trudeau Foundation contempt for
intelligence services and many many
other problems we know so much about the
reasons for which we should be asking
for a real public inquiry not for this
buddy buddy act with his friend when
will this prime minister put an end
to this these policies that are harmful
for Quebec and very very very helpful to
China I'm sorry I'm going to have to ask
the honorable prime minister to stop for
a second
we had started getting better now all of
a sudden everybody's getting excited
again maybe it's because the end of
question period is coming and maybe I'll
just skip to the last question and then
work my way back and that might work out
better but I'm going to let the Prime
Minister continue and we'll see if I
have to resort to that the right
honorable prime minister